my name's Lewis baseman I'm the
detective superintendent from the
Metropolitan Police to my colleague Mr
James Collins Chief City Contender here
in Sussex Bliss we'll just read out some
short statements and obviously at the
end we'll have to take some questions
um following any questions you have
following the statements we're about to
make
so obviously I'll continue continuing
the extensive searches for the missing
baby of constance Martin and Mark Gordon
after they were located in Brighton last
night
the pair were arrested in Starman
fillers at around 21 30 hours on Monday
the 27th of February after a member of
the public saw them in the shop
in hollingbury place
I can confirm that they were initially
arrested on suspicion of child neglect
I can now confirm
that they have been further arrested on
suspicion of gross negligence
manslaughter and that they remain in
custody at police stations in Sussex
the baby was not with them and we have
not found the baby at yet
the police helicopter sniffer dogs
thermal imaging cameras and drones are
being used to assist officers on the
ground we currently have over 200
officers from multiple units across the
Metropolitan Police and Sussex police
involved in the search
throughout this investigation our key
priority has been finding the baby
and we remain committed to that
there is a significant amount of police
search activity in Open Spaces to the
north of Brighton near to where the
couple were arrested last night
before the arrest the last known
sighting of the couple was in New Haven
on Wednesday the 8th of January I am
therefore appealing to members of the
public between Brighton and New Haven to
report
they may have seen people sleeping I'd
also ask people living in these areas to
report any suspicious Behavior
equally if you are out walking in these
areas and you discover something
you think is pertinent to the
investigation please don't hesitate to
contact us no matter how insignificant
it may seem support from the public is
vital and it is the support from the
public that has been key to date in this
investigation
we have received a large number of phone
calls from members of the public drawing
the investigation
I would like to thank everyone who's
come forward with information
and especially the person who quickly
called the police last night after
spotting Constance and Mark
our colleagues from Sussex police were
on scene within minutes to make the
arrest
we are very grateful for the support
that they are providing
and any information that could assist I
asked you to ring 999 immediately
and I'll hand over to my colleague
thank you
so we are supporting the Metropolitan
Police on this extensive search
thanks to the vigilance of a member of
the public our officers were on scene
within minutes of the reporting sighting
and made arrests
an immediate search was launched
including the National Police Air
Service helicopter drones dog units and
every available officer and staff member
from across the force
these searches are ongoing and the
public can expect to see an increased
police presence in the area as well as a
dedicated response to any information
from the public
we acknowledge that there may be some
disruption to the people living and
working in the area and we thank those
people for their patience and
understanding at this time
I'd like to thank the local community
further for all the help they have given
us so far we have an extensive search
area and will be in this community for
some time
some people may want to know what they
can do to help
we just ask you to remain Vigilant and
please report anything of note to us
if you have any information that will
support the search please call 101 and
in an emergency please dial 999 we have
dedicated call handlers available to
talk with you thank you
so we're happy to take some questions if
anyone would like to start
TV
have you come to the arrest further
arrest on suspicion
so obviously the arrests occurred
obviously last night obviously just
after 9 30.
we've had significant periods of time in
the custody facility with both contents
and Mark at this time we have not
furthered that information which has now
obviously led to the position where we
feel that the risk is getting so great
that we now have to consider the
possibility that the baby has come to
harm and that will now be subject as
part of that investigation by the
officers involved have they admitted to
that
with the interview process was
continuing and note at this time it's
purely based on the fact as part of the
investigation strategy but I will you
know reiterate that we still remain
focused on a search and an open land
search to find the baby safe and well
they started cooperating at all with
earlier on they didn't they weren't even
revealing the gender of the baby have
they
've given any information at all about
that no we further no information in
relation to the gender of the baby
um as part of the post arrest or as part
of the investigation at the moment
I I wouldn't be drawn on a time frame I
think whilst we still have hope that the
baby can be found safe and well we must
retain that hope and as you see the
number of officers we have deployed on
that open search however as time
progresses as the whether it is it is
closing tonight as it was last night in
terms of
the cold the coldness and the impact
that would have on a baby clearly the
risk is getting higher and we have to be
open to the fact that this may not end
in the way we would like but we need to
remain hateful and that is why over this
late turn today into the night and you
will still see the numbers of officers
deployed on that search for the very
reason of locating the baby what do you
think's brought them to brighter or
sorry what do you think has brought them
to Brighton and have you got any
information which suggests that they've
been in touch with any third party at
all
no at this at this time obviously and I
think it's key into the previous
um
releases and in discussions we've had
with you with yourselves in the media is
you know we've seen from the 5th of
January when this incident occurred and
started in Manchester that they moved
very quickly from Manchester to
Liverpool to Essex throughout London
before obviously coming to Sussex at
this time we have and didn't have as
part of all of that investigation
process information that was you know
brought us to reasons of location and it
will form part of the investigation now
obviously to date and will continue and
that would be part of that in our
strategy to work out why and why they
came to Sussex and where they have been
in that intervening time as well and
before he was arrested it appears that
he was with a stick and there's been
some footage shared online of the pair
of them walking around can you confirm
that can you help us out with that we
are looking into that footage I can't
confirm it right now uh I hope to be
able to come back later with um
I've seen the footage and we are looking
into that footage and
they you know they both um obviously
were booked into custody and as part of
that process we would have and have
received the appropriate medical
assessments about that booking in Period
what they were actually saying were they
living rough were they in the allotments
were they actually on the Downs where's
your focus of the search going so the
working hypothesis Still Remains that um
we believe them to be and have been in
the open land and open areas that is why
our our focus and our search is as where
it is we are cognizant to the fact that
you know there are outbuildings is a
vast amount of land I've been my
colleague in around the the geography so
the the location as you know from being
here today uh is vast uh we're looking
at the sort of corridor uh between where
they were last cited and here of about
seven miles by 13 mole sort of length in
duration so 91 square miles worth to be
searched and we just encourage the
public to be vigilant if you see
anything please report it our dedicated
officers are working their way through
that and our Focus really remains at
this time while there is still some hope
for finding this young baby on doing so
I've been abundantly camping equipment
at this time no got no further
information from
no this time we haven't got any
information from the custody process
that's supporting the location or the
welfare of the baby just going back to
when they were arrested just going back
to the point when they were arrested a
couple of things quickly can you give us
a bit more detail about the member of
the public who reported it and how that
unfolded were they a shop worker did
they follow them up here a bit how did
that happen and also going back to that
footage it appears that
um Constance Martin may have been
wearing a puffer jacket and a dress and
Mark Gordon also in a puffer jacket and
bag of Travelers again with a walking
stick what were they wearing when they
arrested and did he have the stick when
they arrested and what I can say around
the uh the arrest is it it was a
diligent member of the public who
observed them accessing a cash machine
and then further entering the shop and
they remained Vigilant bringing 999
which alerted Sussex police which saw a
response from the initial 999 call to
the arrest of about six minutes and that
obviously was also the movement of the
couple and just short of the location
where we are right now last question and
just a follow-on on their condition
during the arrest
is anything in their conditions
suggesting that they have been living
Outdoors for a sustained period of time
yeah I think you know we can quite happy
to confirm you know from from these
initial assessments that we have which
then links into our the rationale and
reason for the for the why we are doing
open land searches is because
um upon locating the couple and they're
resting the couple there is information
you know very much significant
intelligence information as part of that
arrest process that brings us to a
hypothesis that they have been and
spending a significant time Outdoors
um living uh in the in the countryside
and obviously the the vasta land that
you obviously have here in Sussex and my
apologies we'll do one more question and
then
maybe a possibility if someone was
taking care of the baby on their behalf
if that's the possibility you are
entertaining we always have to keep our
open mind to the investigation it is a
reason why we did offer the 10 000 pound
reward and that ten thousand pound
reward
remains open because what we know is
that Constance and Mark did have a
substantial amount of cash within this
investigation what we don't know is
drawing the movements how they come
across an individual that has taken pity
to the cause and through cash that's
available to them allowed them to seek
refuge in either a premises or
outbuildings and it's to those
individuals you know we say that that is
where the reward sits we have to keep
open-minded and it is one of the
hypotheses that we are working to
that point so I'm afraid I'm afraid no
more questions but we just want to leave
you with the statement that we thank you
for your time this afternoon we thank
the public for their support on this and
we want to work diligently to see
whether we can still find this baby at
this time so thank you very much
everyone thank you
that was James Collis Chief
superintendent of Sussex police saying
thank you there at the end alongside him
uh carrying out most of the press
conference was detective superintendent
Lewis bassford from the Metropolitan
Police during their update we have
learned of course that the missing baby
has not been found but there are
extensive search continues that the
police are still hoping to find the baby
safe and well though of course their
updates over the last couple of hours
have shown a fallen confidence in that
indeed they had arrested both Constance
Martin and Mark Gordon last night on
suspicion of gross negligent
manslaughter though not charged them
with it yet various reporters there
asked questions whether the couple had
indicated that the baby had come to harm
and the answer to that was no but they
are considering that possibility either
way they did also mention once again
that they still do not know the gender
of the baby which indicates the limit of
the information that Constance Martin
and Mark Gordon have been giving to them
that they mentioned the the size of the
area they are searching between New
Haven where they were last sighted on
the 8th of January and Brighton where
they arrested yesterday are of some 91
square miles seven miles by 13 miles and
they did thank diligent members of the
public who have been helpful here in
particular the person that noticed the
couple last night at a cash point and
saw them going into a shop and
reiterated that from that diligent
member of the Public's 999 call arrest
was made within uh six minutes their
hypothesis is that the couple had been
living in the outdoors in recent weeks
so let's bring in Skies policing analyst
Graham wettone Graham firstly your
reaction
uh to this charge and not charge excuse
me to the suspicion of gross negligent
manslaughter being the reason for the
arrest though as I said not yet charged
no yeah they further arrested them uh
for gross negligence Mass looks and that
gives the police more powers to detain
them overnight bear in mind they
arrested last night at 9 30. police
initially after 24 hours to either to
charge somebody with an offense or
release them so a further arrest and it
clearly Mass laws is a serious offense
the further rest of this kind will give
the police powers to further detain them
uh overnight and into tomorrow while I
continue to search for the baby as was
said it's probably a reasonable
assumption now if the baby has been left
outside on its own as we're coming into
you know at the half of the second half
of today that there is an assumption
though there is hope still that they
find a baby somewhere but again arrested
him for gross negligence manslaughter
gives the police further powers to
design them and continue the
investigations
and and just just quickly Graham if if
they don't find the baby by tomorrow
then even with this further arrest
they'd have to release the couple at
some point tomorrow
no they can then apply for a warrant for
further detention at a magistrate school
but again that there's further processes
to go through as part of the
investigation but they can extend it
through a few more days yet depending on
the how the investigation goes what
information they get in uh and if the
couple starts talking at all so there's
still some time for the police to to
detain them but again the reason they've
arrested them further for a more serious
offense is so that processes can be
considered and applied if need be
I want to bring in now as well Aisha
zahid who was listening to that update
right there uh as it was happening and
Aisha some of your key takeaways
well the biggest detail that came out of
that press conference is the fact that
on top of being arrest for suspicion of
child neglect like Constance Martin
Gordon Mark Gordon where yesterday when
they were arrested they now face a
further arrest of Suspicion of gross
negligence manslaughter and that comes
because police say that now the risk to
the baby is extremely high the risk is
so great but they consider that the baby
May well have come to harm May well have
had come to harm however they did add
that they are still hopeful that that is
not the outcome of all of this and they
remain hopeful and that's why they're
going to continue to dedicate the amount
of resources they already have to this
search they've got over 200 officers
between the Metropolitan Police and
Sussex police taking part in this search
during that conference as well police
also said that they in their lives
litigation now believe that Constance
Martin the newborn baby and Mark Gordon
had been staying living in open land
camping out in open land so that is
really going to be the focus of their
search but they also spoke about just
how wide of an area to search this is
they said it's about 19 square miles
which they will be focusing their
efforts on and that will include
anything the open land the allotment
area out buildings they really are
devoted to this search hopeful that the
baby has not come to harm but
acknowledging that the risks given the
circumstances are extremely high just to
remind you this baby has not received
any medical attention from medical
professionals since it was born about
two months ago it's believed it hasn't
been checked over by any doctors any
midwives on top of that the conditions
over the last two months in some cases
have been Sub-Zero it's been incredibly
cold only last night it was Sub-Zero in
the area so of course that or adding to
their beliefs that the baby May well
have come to a risk
Aisha thanks uh so much for that and
obviously do stick around with us so
Graham just to come back to some of the
takeaways you have from from the press
conference I mean amazing that the
police went off said they still don't
know the gender of the baby I guess an
indication of uh how little uh help the
couple are willing to offer yeah that
was a big takeaway for me clearly and it
was a direct question asked the
detective superintendent from the Met
um they still don't have a gender of the
baby or seen in any other information
whatsoever the couple clearly are not
answering any questions during the
interview process that is ongoing will
still take place but no other
information at all which is why you'll
see such a large and expansive search
being conducted by and Sussex officers
and so many offices from last night
right away through today and we'll
probably continue through tonight as
well and I think the Sussex Chief
superintendent mentioned there's going
to be disruptions to the area to local
people because of the extent of the
search helicopters drowned and dogs
involved as well
um there was another question in there
which uh the uh James uh no sorry was uh
uh superintendent Lewis bassford from
from the Met answered halfway through
his answer he was asked uh whether the
couple had admitted that the baby had
come to harm and he he seemed to say no
in his answer to that so it's it's more
part of the hypothesis that the the
police are building up as opposed to
something that's been confirmed
yeah I picked up on that he didn't
answer it directly with it with a
director you know direct response as
such but I think again looking at the
time frame looking if the baby's been
left on its own overnight last night and
today
um and again to give the police the pass
to to extend the Detention of the cup
and keep and keep questioning them um I
think it was a natural progression to to
further arrest him for gross negligence
manslaughter and then continue
investigating asking questions and see
if they can get any information from the
couple whatsoever
we discussed that a couple of hours ago
about the journey that they'd been on
and how relevant that was to the search
area New Haven Brighton as as the air is
mentioned we also got a number there 90
plus square miles just uh how big an
area is that for a police search like
this and that's huge that's a huge area
to conduct a search and I think you
heard then an appeal to the public for
anybody that's seen anything New Haven
to Bright and that they they're not
supposed you know specified the actual
areas albeit is very big but anyone
that's seen anything until ring it in
anything they found that might be of use
to the search itself tent I think has
been mentioned as well any indication
where the couple have been in a period
of time mentioned between New Haven and
Brighton anyway they've slept anybody's
found anything that has been discarded
by maybe someone who thought was rough
sleeping in the area uh the appeal was
sort of public to bring it in the police
will then work through
um they'll prioritize actions as they
come in they look at the Timeline they
look at the time frame that date
mentioned by whoever calls it in they'll
pull together almost like a picture and
where the couple have been and try and
locate where the baby is